mais pour revenir sur cette affaire mais
aussi parler des manifestations du jour
thomas porte syndicaliste cgt et membre
du pcf nous a rejoint thomas porte
bonjour merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france manifestation donc cet
après midi contre la loi sécurité
globale pourquoi il est important pour
vous de vous rendre à cette mobilisation
parce que c'est une loi liberticide et
qui va remettre en cause à la fois le
droit de la presse le droit d'informer
des citoyens et qui au delà de l'article
24 acte un certain nombre de principes
qui sont extrêmement préoccupant et
dangereux pour l'état de droit avec une
privatisation de la sécurité un usage
généralisé des drones et puis vous
l'avez rappelé dans votre édition on a
vu cette semaine l'importance de pouvoir
diffuser des images un cas de violence
policière parce que le producteur de
musique michel qui a été littéralement
passé à tabac par la police sans les
images de son studio il serait
certainement aujourd'hui en prison avec
des motifs utilisés par les policiers
dont on a vu qu'ils avaient fait des
faux en écriture pour se couvrir
donc c'est important que l'institution
policière qui aujourd'hui traversé par
des problèmes systémiques soit contrôlé
par la démocratie elle ne peut pas vivre
d'impunité c'est ce que veut faire
gérald darmanin avec cet article 24 qui
en réalité une revendication des
syndicats les plus violents et
corporatiste de la police alors vous
rappeliez effectivement la sphère michel
est clair emmanuel macron s'est dit très
choqué on vient de le voir est ce que
cette affaire elle peut finalement faire
bouger les lignes selon vous sur la loi
sécurité globale j'espère qu'elle va au
moins entraînés à minimale retrait
intégral de ce projet de loi parce que
c'est ce qu'on demande on ne demande pas
simplement l'abrogation de l'article 24
mai on regarde en demande le retrait
intégral de cette loi mais vous savez
les moniales macron il peut être choquer
des images mais c'est pas la première
fois qu'on a des violences policières
c'est pas la première fois qu'on les
découvre et on a quand même tous en
mémoire la sphère de ses riches ou via
qui a été tué par des policiers c'est là
aussi grâce à des images filmées par des
gens dans la rue qu'on a pu montrer la
culpabilité des policiers en un
véritable problème avec l'institution
policière dans ce pays nous avons besoin
d'un débat démocratique là dessus de
revoir la question du maintien de
l'ordre et mis bout-à-bout les éléments
qui s'accumulent avec ce qu'on a connu
aussi place de république la semaine
dernière avec des migrants et des exilés
et vaincu à coups de pied des avocats
frappé des journalistes molesté par les
par les policiers
interroge donc aujourd'hui nous avons
besoin d'un débat approfondi n'a pas
besoin d'un président de la république
qui se dit choquée nous avons besoin de
réponses politiques très importantes de
remettre à plat cette institution pour
retisser le lien entre la police et les
citoyens qui aujourd'hui est
considérablement dégradé ce qui est
particulièrement inquiétant
on va y revenir justement sur ce lien
entre les français et la police mais
avant vous le disiez la question des
violences policières elles datent pas
d'hier on se souvient notamment des
nombreuses alertes lors du début des
manifestations des gilet jaune
1 pourquoi ces violences selon vous
n'avez pas alors autant ému au sommet de
l'état basset c'est une réponse fait que
j'ai pas mais c'est absolument choquant
effectivement d'avoir aujourd'hui des
propos pour cette personne là qui a été
passée à tabac mais vous l'avez rappelé
dans notre question le mouvement d'un
gilet jaune a quand même été très
fortement réprimé on avait des gens qui
ont perdu des yeux on a des gens qui ont
perdu démène avec un préfet qui est
toujours en place et qui continue de
sévir et qui est extrêmement violents et
donc aujourd'hui on demande à minima le
départ en monsieur l'allemand ne peut
pas rester préfet de police de paris
après les exactions qu'ils continuent de
commettre
on l'a connu par le passé à bordeaux
c'était déjà quelqu'un de très violents
donc c'est vrai qu'on a depuis que
emmanuel macron est arrivé au bout on a
une répression de toute la contestation
sociale quelle qu'elle soit d'ailleurs
on a eu les gilet jaune et le mouvement
contre la réforme des retraites
donc à chaque fois qu'il ya une colère
populaire dans ce pays la réponse
utilisée est une réponse répressive donc
c'est ok on empile les lois liberticides
justement didier lallement qui a écrit
une lettre aux policiers on en a pris
connaissance ce matin et le préfet de
police de paris demande
on garde la pêche aussi de tenir la
ligne républicaine jusqu'au bout qu'est
ce qu'il entend par là d'après vous je
sais pas mais c'est quand même
extrêmement préoccupant cette formule
teulière la ligne républicaine jusqu'au
bout on peut tout mettre derrière et
encore une fois c'est certainement un
appel à ne pas céder mais c'est
aujourd'hui le comportement des
policiers il est aussi due à des ordres
qui sont donnés par la hiérarchie vous
savez quand une violence gangrène une
institution c'est parce qu'il ya un
sentiment d'impunité
il ya un sentiment de protection et en
vérité pour une deux trois affaires qui
sortent avec des images qui sont lus par
des gens combien de cas dans les
quartiers populaires qui aujourd'hui ne
sont pas décelé combien de volos
policière
l'igpn doit être une instance qui ne
répond plus à aucun contrôle puisque sur
plus de 800 à faire peut-être deux ou
trois qui sont classés avec des
procédures contre des policiers
donc on a aussi un problème de contrôle
en interne de la police donc tout ça
mérite un débat profond et la réponse
apportée par le gouvernement avec 7,7
ce projet de loi qui en plus est une est
une blague puisque c'est utilisé par
deux députés
ma chronique qui l'ont déposé pour
éviter d'avoir un avis du conseil d'état
pour éviter d'avoir un impact d'études à
avoir non débat parlementaire passer ça
en pleine nuit alors que nous sommes en
plein d'état des gens d'urgence
sanitaire c'est vraiment pas à la
hauteur de ce dont nous avons besoin
aujourd'hui et dans ce contexte tendu
que nous sommes en train de vivre ce
qu'il n'y a pas un an - adam g à m tous
les policiers dans le même sac
mais aujourd'hui la question elle est
celle de l'institution et on n'a jamais
dit que tous les policiers étaient
violents nous avons dit qu'ils avaient
des violences policières qui a un
problème avec cette institution et qu'il
faut la remettre à plat et qu'il faut la
redéfinir notamment ses missions et son
maintien de l'ordre
il faut redonner un rôle démocratique et
républicain à cette police parce qu'on
peut véritablement se poser la question
aujourd'hui est ce que cette police est
toujours républicaine mais c'est aussi
une réponse politique parce qu'il faut
pas exonérer le politique dans ces
moments-là des directives et des
missions qui donne aux gens qui sont sur
le terrain
donc c'est ça le véritable sujet est
aujourd'hui le c'est aussi un manque de
courage quand même des manuels macro et
gérald darmanin qui se retranchent
toujours derrière les forces de l'ordre
mais qui n'assument pas leurs
responsabilités qui sont celles quand
même de donner des ordres et de donner
des missions et notamment de réfléchir à
ce que je dis qui est très important
c'est là la stratégie du maintien de
l'ordre en france qui est d'ailleurs
inégalée dans les autres pays d'europe
on n'a jamais vu des pays qui tire avec
des ailes bd sur des manifestants qui
utilisent des grenades de
désencerclement hauteur de visage de
taille humaine
donc on a eu un degré de violence qui
est en train d'accélérer et je crois que
ce qu'on a connu cette semaine avec
michel doit quand même alerté en disant
que maintenant ça suffit
parce que ça va être quoi la prochaine
étape en fait merci beaucoup comme un
porc d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes syndicaliste cgt
membre du pcf